let me tell you a story for decades
silicon valley has been the most
competitive place in the world as soon
as you launched your great idea 10 other
entrepreneurs would be right behind you
with nearly identical products as soon
as the iphone launched android wasn't
far behind when uber started taking over
investors scrambled to fund lyft and
even after facebook became dominant
twitter snapchat and instagram all
fought to steal attention most of the
time this was driven by entrepreneurs
just wanting to make a better product
but sometimes it was just because
investors wanted a piece of a lucrative
new market and they couldn't get shares
in the leading company early enough but
all that's changing investors are now
colluding to create a single monopoly in
each new market that emerges and they're
killing startups in the process consider
stripe which for the past decade has
been the fastest growing fintech company
in silicon valley most startups would be
lucky to secure investment from a single
top-tier venture capital firm but stripe
has 17 backing it and this creates a
problem see when a venture capital firm
invests in one company they can't invest
in direct competitors so all of a sudden
if you want to start a stripe competitor
you simply can't it gets worse though
see stripe was a part of the prestigious
accelerator program y combinator and
because stripe has done so well they can
now prevent new fintech companies from
ever having a chance to enter the
program and it doesn't stop there many
companies that sell products to small
businesses get their start by launching
on hacker news it's a massively popular
website for startup announcements but
because stripe is so powerful they can
kill any positive stories about
competitors this sinister plot is
crushing the competitive spirit of
silicon valley and stifling new
innovation there's only one problem none
of this is true
see this story is from a viral twitter
thread posted by the founder of a stripe
competitor the author's name is ryan
breslow and although it's easy to debunk
most of his claims i still think that we
can learn a lot from this story ryan
makes three key claims in his thread so
let's go through them one at a time
first he argues that stripe deliberately
raised money from all the top tier
silicon valley investors in order to
block competition and no one can deny
that stripe does have an incredible
roster of investors i mean come on even
elon musk is an investor and he
basically never makes angel investments
but can this really block new companies
well markets don't usually work that way
if stripes only protection against
competition was having lots of cash in
the bank other investors would flood
into the sector in order to get a piece
of the action and in practice that's
exactly what's happened ryan has been
able to raise over 1 billion dollars for
his company bolt which by all accounts
is still very early stage so it doesn't
seem like finding investors is a real
problem and startup funding is at a
ridiculous all-time high right now we'll
dive into these macro trends in a minute
but we still need to talk about y
combinator in his thread ryan claims
that y combinator turned him down
because he was competing with stripe but
why c funds direct competitors all the
time in fact it's one of the main
complaints about recent batches
investors are constantly posting snarky
tweets about how y combinator companies
look the same and there are too many
direct competitors in each batch the
idea that yc has held back on funding
stripe competitors looks ridiculous once
you take one look at the list of most
valuable companies that have come out of
yc 23 of the top 100 y combinator
companies compete with stripe in some
way now many of these companies operate
internationally like razor pay in india
but stripe is already a global company
so make no mistake these companies are
in direct competition with each other
and other y combinator companies are
building businesses in america that go
head to head with stripe like modern
treasury which offers banking as a
service and competes with stripes
treasury product directly and we can't
forget about crypto either lots of smart
people argue that cryptocurrency poses
an existential threat to classic fintech
in the long term and yc funded one of
the biggest crypto exchanges in the
world coinbase ryan may be wrong about
his claim that yc doesn't fund
competitors but he didn't stop there he
went on to accuse stripe of manipulating
hacker news into killing stories about
his company that's a serious allegation
so let's look at the evidence he
provides ryan claims that on april 18
2018 he submitted a new product
announcement to hacker news things were
going well at first and the post was
getting traffic but then all of a sudden
a similar post about stripe appeared and
his post died off there's only one issue
with this though the stripe post
actually went up first a full two hours
before ryan posted and anyone can see
this evidence through the timestamps and
the internet archive if you dig into the
actual substance of the two articles
it's easy to see why his post failed to
take off it was written for a very
stodgy corporate audience and most
people who browse hacker news are
software engineers i mean come on the
site is called hacker news for a reason
hackers like seeing deeper dives into
how new technologies actually work and
this gets to the underlying issue here
ryan's story certainly stretches the
truth in pretty much every way possible
but it did do one thing right it got him
a ton of attention and that was his real
goal here the thread got nearly 10 000
likes and he basically became the main
character on twitter for the entire week
sure lots of folks laughed it off but
plenty of people did take it seriously
and they might be more likely to become
bold customers now marketing is a bit of
a dirty word in silicon valley everyone
wants to build a product that is so
incredible that they don't need to spend
any money to grow their customer base
but that's a rare situation drawing
attention is incredibly important and if
you can get people talking about your
product for free that's going to lead to
hyper growth at the early stage and even
though stripe has a great product this
kind of free content marketing was
incredibly important when they first
launched they weren't posting
conspiratorial twitter threads but they
were thinking about how to capture the
attention of developers who had spent
years struggling with awkward payment
systems the core of stripes early
content marketing strategy centered
around just seven lines of code that
could be used to quickly integrate
payments into any website it's easy to
think of this as purely a product
innovation and it was but by distilling
their integration down to just seven
lines of code they immediately had a
sound byte that could go viral on sites
like hacker news back when stripe first
launched on hacker news in september of
2011 they flew straight to the top and
instantly received hundreds of positive
comments the landing page they had
designed made stripes value proposition
incredibly clear and more importantly it
was designed to appeal to developers
there were already plenty of established
players in the payments market but the
collison brothers had discovered a
secret that would allow them to disrupt
all of their existing competitors they
knew that developers had an incredible
amount of control over which
technologies and services would be used
at the companies where they work most
senior executives don't understand code
so they just want something that works
older payments companies thought that
they needed to sell to those
non-technical executives in order to
sign contracts but the collisons knew
that developers were really the key to
hyper growth today stripe is dominant
and ryan breslow wants his company bolt
to unseat stripe as the number one
player in payments so he's taking a page
out of stripes playbook and trying to
attract attention as aggressively as
possible and even though he sometimes
steps over the line he's done a great
job of distilling bolt's key value
proposition into a digestible sound bite
see bold is laser focused on one click
checkout this technology was pioneered
by amazon and dramatically speeds up
customer interactions all while
increasing conversion rates for years
amazon had a patent on one click but now
it's an open playing field there's a
problem though see stripe actually has a
one-click checkout product and they
launched it way back in 2014 but
marketing taglines are incredibly sticky
so today many people don't even realize
stripe has this functionality bolt on
the other hand has built their brand
around one click from inception so
that's what they're known for but
there's a bigger question that we need
to answer here though why is ryan
pushing boundaries so aggressively here
in general social media rewards
controversy no one wants to comment on a
post that they feel indifferent about so
creating content that strikes an
emotional chord is key to virality but
it has its limits if you go too
controversial you'll face a backlash and
that's what happened to ryan shortly
after posting this thread lots of
prominent silicon valley investors
called him out for twisting the facts
and smearing his competitor this type of
content marketing can be incredibly
rewarding when it pays off but it's also
very risky so why is ryan doing it well
i think it has a lot to do with trends
in the broader financial markets right
now see startup valuations are at an
all-time high and that's a double-edged
sword for entrepreneurs on the one hand
it's great to be able to raise millions
of dollars to go build the next
generation of technology but on the
other hand these valuations come with
massive expectations and if you don't
deliver on your financial forecasts
you'll be under a lot of pressure from
investors now to be clear there's
nothing wrong with a company being worth
billions of dollars as long as they can
back that up with big sales numbers and
high monthly growth but everyone seems
to think that bolt is simply too small
to justify their multi-billion dollar
valuation startup valuations are often
driven by revenue multiples if your
business is growing quickly and you're
making 10 million dollars you might be
able to raise money at 100 million
valuation that's a 10x revenue multiple
and you won't see that often in public
markets only at the early stage when
companies are doubling or tripling
revenue every year investors are
basically betting that the growth will
continue and the company will be worth
even more in the future this normally
isn't a problem during normal times but
today we're living in strange times that
are anything but normal interest rates
are at all time lows and that means that
investors have to hunt around for
riskier investments in order to earn
positive returns money typically
invested in low yield bonds might flow
to higher interest rate debt dollars
invested in debt shifts over to public
equities and now we're seeing hedge
funds cross over into startup investing
all in search of higher returns these
cascading effects have created a glut of
funding for new companies and now there
is 900 billion dollars allocated towards
startups this is across several stages
traditional venture capitalists have 440
billion dollars and growth focused
private equity firms have 310 billion
there's also 155 billion sitting in spac
funds ready to take startups public it's
an unprecedented amount of money and
it's causing the number of unicorns to
skyrocket typically reaching a 1 billion
valuation is an incredibly rare
milestone but last year the number of
new startups valued over 1 billion
dollars more than tripled valuations are
getting absolutely insane and you don't
have to take it from me one of our good
friends invested in a company's seed
round at a one billion dollar valuation
raising money at astronomical valuations
might seem great in the moment but he
creates a huge amount of pressure and i
think that's what's driving ryan to get
so aggressive about his content
marketing strategy he has tons of
investors who need bolt to absolutely
dominate payments and quickly or else
they could lose money so as much as i
disagree with the core points of ryan's
thread i have a ton of empathy for the
guy he's clearly a great founder and
there's no question that bolt is a real
company that helps speed up customer
checkouts one of the biggest reasons why
startup valuations have gotten so high
is because hedge funds have been
abandoning their traditional strategies
and crossing over into startup investing
but before we dig into that let me tell
you about masterworks.io as we've seen
the traditional financial markets have
been crazy lately but masterworks
unlocks a new market that has previously
only been available to billionaire art
collectors the idea is straightforward
masterworks allows you to invest in
world famous artworks from banksy monet
and other iconic artists for just a
fraction of what these pieces would
typically cost getting started with
masterworks is super easy you just visit
their website create an account browse
their artwork and then start
diversifying your portfolio with one of
the most stable assets around the
contemporary art market hasn't behaved
like most other financial assets in fact
contemporary art prices outpaced the s p
500 total return by 164 percent from
1995 to 2021 now putting together a
portfolio of contemporary art would
normally cost millions of dollars at the
very least but masterworks offers a
secondary market where you can trade
shares with other members just like you
would sell a stock on a trading app i'll
be honest i was excited when masterworks
reached out to me i'd seen their ads on
basically every technology publication i
read regularly and they were super
excited to support the channel i have
lots of family members who have studied
fine art let me tell you art investments
make for way better thanksgiving
conversations you can skip the wait list
by clicking the link in the description
and it helps support the channel so go
check it out now back to those hedge
funds that are changing how startups get
funded tiger global just raised a
massive 11 billion venture fund and it's
going to have a huge impact on silicon
valley i analyzed tiger's strategy and
boiled it down to three key takeaways in
this video here so watch this one next
thanks a lot